he's Shaquille O'Neal the NBA on TNT
hall-of-famer joining us where are you
right now Shaq oh my household I'm sorry
I missed you the other two times I was
scuba diving and when I was batted in
the shark I lost my phone at the bottom
of the abyss of the ocean I apologize
sir all right and I believe you I think
that that is the reason why you were
unable to join us the last time what is
the coolest thing in our house coolest
thing about house will probably be when
I walk into the room that are dedicated
to my father because keep in mind when I
was young my father used to take all my
trophies and I finally asked him why he
took all my trophies and his a salwar so
you never be satisfied so after you
passed away I got all my trophies from a
high school college the pros I got all
my championship rings everything's
because in whom dedicated him when did
you fall in love with Superman I fell
all over Superman when I first went to
the movie uh my god it looks like
yourself jumping over buildings racing
trains and just you know being stronger
than everyone and there that my name
started with s I was like you know I'm
I'm the new Superman so like I really
went home and got a t-shirt got trouble
for it to the magic marker put Superman
mm on my chest and I told my mom I was
Superman she's I know baby I know
wait how old were you when you when you
put a sharpie s on your on your arm uh I
was about nine years old but did you say
anything to your dad or your mom about
getting a tattoo actually I was
terrified knows about my first yearly so
on so I got a small one first little I
came home I was like I don't approve of
it but you're an adult now you're
responsible adult so go ahead and then I
just went crazy got both mom and it was
pretty no screws if I had a little girl
I probably wouldn't have not one tattoo
there's a lot of people feel that way
you know in the in the moment okay the
craziest tattoo you ever got in the
moment was what I have
I have a gorilla smiling on my right
bicep on the inside my right buster
what were you just bored one day and you
said I'm gonna get out more you can
check out the big podcast with Shaq at
podcast 1.com we had Kareem on last hour
and we were talking about all these
great teams in history and how they
would stack up against the Golden State
Warriors and it was Kareem who said you
didn't even mention Shaq's Lakers he
goes how would the Warriors stop Shaq so
that you said they couldn't do anything
with you what your thoughts on you and
Kobe against this Golden State team uh
you know the first thing you have to
take into account which rules are we
plan by reading about my rule now
today's vlog after today's rules we kill
them because just like you can't hand
panchik Steph Curry can I check Oh Reba
and a Bogut Bogut would have been
Australian barbecue chicken yeah that
wouldn't be fair to have Bogut guard you
and he can't really put his eyes on you
oh you know a lot of people like to
bring up to what F what F would have and
the first thing I've taken account of
which which rules are we applied to the
game and then you know secondly you know
I always like I said to myself well you
know let's just go let's just go one
down lap top point guard Steph Curry
probably would have did a number on you
know you probably got a shot off on D
fish but you not think I'll be shocked
when he gave him loved his money clay
and Thompson I gotta get that you I
gotta give that to to Kobe me and Beau
gonna give that to me
for there's no long play them up now
[ __ ] about horse big shot Bob's I will
be in the post for game on - child's
play defense and it Dre my child -
double I'm gonna kick it the Big Shot
Bob over it for the shot so you know a
lot of people like to talk about
Showtime Showtime was a great team but
the best leg of team is team that almost
went 16 hello the 1501 team know how
people don't like to mention the team
but yeah I think we still have the best
record along
with a photo photo think they weren't
12-1 but you know in my opinion I think
we would we would kill them
only because I definitely would have put
put clay and and step on the ground when
it come to the leg with a single
definitely I don't know if they could
take that pain two or three times when
did it change where you couldn't put you
need the physicality when did it change
it change my luck itself and it was talk
implanted and you know guys just you
know guys just don't really play that
way more like Steph Curry goes to land
and I would say anybody touch them up
yet which is I guess is a you know good
thing for him but like Harmon when I was
coming in guys like Oakley am alone and
Berkeley and bad boys from the piston
Lam beer he'll put you in your back if
we try to come in there so you know a
lot of guys would eventually come back
in to show that they want sup a lot of
guys you put them on their back they'd
never come back in then I got a whole
slew of mags I want to put him on a back
every time we play dough
they shot jumpers yeah I clear this up
because Mike Brown wanted to tell me
this story and but he was afraid that
the story would get out but then you
brought up the story or Phil Jackson did
of practicing in the nude with the
Lakers Mike Brown said that you may have
done this with the Cavaliers so cleared
up know what happened is is whenever you
be late you're fine so Khumbu Tom's
not no more art our children late so
they want delay so it just hasn't walk
on those who look I'm here I'm not legit
well I'll be back what exactly did you
have on are just [ __ ] [ __ ] did Phil
have a sense of humor about it yeah he
did you know it was like I would only
probably do it once a year like when the
team was chugging I would just have to
you know break that out get guys
laughing and then we're right back on
track the big podcast with Shaq at
podcast one.com what do you see when you
see LeBron James now confidence wise
well you know this he's a very confident
guy I think you know a lot of people
want him to be Mike when he's more like
magic if you look at the chairmanship
he's one yes he's put up great numbers
but you know I always go back to my good
friend Mike Miller's first two
championships one year he had six next
year he is seven with a shoe off D way
putting up big numbers here boss putting
up big numbers it's just that when
you're the main cat people look for you
to always go off but LeBron has went off
but the others have also went off too so
you know Kyrie and love do not get a
pass does a storyline for this year all
year has been okay go and say you won
last year you know yeah uh you know you
want cup of tea injured and yeah when
you went to the finals you played
against LeBron but Kevin was hurt Kyrie
was hurt so now that they're not hurt
and they're down low to everybody saying
LeBron LeBron lebra but you have to say
LeBron
Kyrie and Kevin know all three of those
guys have to play superb especially
Kevin and Kyrie I just got a gotta stop
settling for jumpers and just play I was
there the first two games and and
draymond Green is punking Kevin up you
heard it here first I has your son doing
with Kobe uh they have a matter of you
but I'm sure they'll meet up this summer
so he's going to tutor him and what-what
can Kobe a team that you can't ah
teacher you notice yourself about being
the car you know what guards doing all
that my son is a big member when he was
coming up it was my original father he's
gonna be six eight six nine so always
made him watch Kobe t-mac LeBron and
gods like that but now that he's 611 I
think as a 611 guy that can really shoot
the ball I think if you have card skills
the way the game was played today I
think it actually get his game to the
next level and I have no problem with
him working with the best guys and
business I was I wish I had that
opportunity I kind of had that
opportunity College I wish I had more of
it coach Brown bought a curry he brought
him Bill Russell stuff a bill
Walter so you know bill one work with me
on my passing cream wasn't one told me
that you gotta have a go-to shot he
tried to teach me to jump up cause it
try to teach me the skyhook but I
thought that was a little old-school so
I so I went to the jump hook instead but
you know I would try to call all my
friends in the business know if he's
working out with Colby's gonna work out
with uncle T Mac and I'm gonna get a
couple other players work out with
where's he gonna go to school hey
where's he gonna go to college wherever
wherever you want to go is he gonna be a
one-and-done
Oh probably not okay yeah you're
probably not whoa one and done
definitely not - probably not after
three maybe ah because you know a lot of
guys a lot of guys go because I try to
help out their family but his dad is
pretty well off so I'm gonna try to hurt
stay and have fun
a lot of game because you know once you
get into the world of the cone adult is
one word you need to worry about FICA
and let's see understand what emergency
stayin before I let you go I somebody
brought this up about Chris Jackson
Mahmoud Abdul Rahul and his ability his
handle quick shot it is there any
comparison with Steph Curry and your
former teammate Chris Jackson uh yes the
only only difference is curry shoots a
long ball a lot more a lot frequently a
little bit consistent but Chris Jackson
was very quick off the ball
he had the quicker Sheldon college ball
he was a mid-range assassin and you know
he did it and then I played with another
guy in here that there was still curry
does he does in a spurts
however he's getting trouble for doing
that's white chocolate Jason wimps he
had that ability to just come down
shade the defensive pull-up from
everywhere and every time that he would
hit those shots crowd go crazy but Steph
does it Steph does a super hurry Jason
Williams looks like he could still play
Shaq yeah he can play the host rezzy
lives are two houses down from I watched
those videos where he's planned pickup
with all these young guys and still
doing all the same stuff he did when he
was playing in the NBA you're great
crazy
uh hey good good heavy on and enjoy your
you're snorkeling scuba diving and be
safe as always okay and again I
apologize for missing the last time all
the skydiving in my phone uh lands out
of my pocket over the Serengeti I tried
to go down and get it but it was
alligators and lions and tigers and
bears oh my
and I just couldn't retrieve my phone on
my call I apologize right I believe you
Shaq thank you thank you for joining
he's uh the big podcast with Shaq on
podcast wonk on the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience